This is a song that was written to a track that's a Loop that was made with the sounds that I made with my mouth.
Good morning, John.
If I had a dollar bill, I would give a piece to everyone.
There's a hole I wanna fill that gets smaller every song that's sung.
Cause when I make a meal, or when I kiss a girl, well this might sound a bit surreal, but that's me giving to the world.
I wanna buy the world a coke.
I'd do better telling you to eat your wheaties.
I wanna sing a song.
I don't wanna give you type two diabetes.
So when you party hard, or when you go to the bank,
or when you mow the yard, or you name your new son Hank, well you're moving it along.
This is the method that drives the whole thing forward.
It's possible I'm wrong,
but I think that praise is absolutely unheard.
There's so much that must be done and so many folks to do it.
And I know sometimes it's hard, but together we get through it.
No one does it all alone, nobody does it all alone.
Nobody does it all aloooooone, nobody does it all alone.
If I had a dollar bill, I would give a piece to everyone.
There's a hole I wanna fill that gets smaller every song that's sung
Thank you to the hundreds of people who created beats using that sounds that I made with my mouth at star.me.
You can still go and beatbox with me, at star.me, if you want to, the link is in the description.
But there was, like, so much of this going on in that video.
I just wanted to do something different and it's black and white because I didn't want you to see the natural colour of my teeth.
Honesty!
So John, that song that I just sang for you and everyone else is about not being special.
And it's about how not being special is not only, like, really normal, it's also really necessary and really wonderful.
All of the normal things that we do every day, taking care of our kids and emptying out septic tanks
and learning things and having fun and being silly,
those are the things that make the world work.
On the other hand, Steve Jobs, one of the most special people of his generation and one of my personal heroes just died a couple of days ago.
And that of course reminds us all how important people like that are.
It's always a little bit dangerous to talk about someone right after they died because we tend to, like, inflate their importance,
but it's kind of difficult for me to imagine inflating the importance of Steve Jobs.
He made what we do possible, John.
From our first computer, the Apple II e that Dad got,
all the way to the computers that we got in 2007 to get ready for this project
and all of the software that we've ever edited any video on: that was all because of Steve Jobs.
John, we are in the very not-unique situation of having a job that depended on Steve Jobs existence.
I didn't know Steve Jobs, I don't know what kind of guy he was, I just know him through the things that he created.
And because of the things that he created, he was important to me and he made my life better
and I think that the world is less good without him.
And maybe that's what we should be trying for in the end.
For, at the end of our lives, for the world to be less good without us.
And if that's the case, maybe we don't have to be special to be like Steve Jobs,
maybe we just have to be good.
John, I'll see you on Monday.